soy marín soy parte del equipo de
educación en caracas de mi yo me sentaba
donde están ustedes ahora era maestra en
una escuela que está en la frontera de
texas y méxico me uní a khan academy y
he estado aquí los últimos dos años he
estado cerca de las escuelas los
maestros los administradores ayudándoles
a resolver cómo echar a andar el
programa khan academy de manera eficaz
muchos de ustedes ya están
familiarizados con lo que es khan
academy que empezamos con sal en pijama
haciendo vídeos para su prima nadie que
vivía en el otro extremo de eeuu para
ayudarle a aprender matemáticas desde
entonces hemos crecido somos una
organización mucho más grande y ahora no
solamente tenemos vídeos tenemos
ejercicios ciencias de la computación
tenemos también un campamento en donde
los chicos están ahora construyendo
robots así que la organización ha
crecido muchísimo quiero solamente que
echemos un vistazo a algunos de los
contenidos en los que nos estamos
enfocando
además de las matemáticas quienes son
los dos vectores que hay que tomar para
hacer el producto cruz pues será la
derivada de r respecto de ese y la
derivada de r
respecto de t puedes ver que el corazón
está rodeado por ambos lados por
costillas verdad
esta es la masa atómica del carbono 12
puntos 0 11 ok
el tipo de cambio varía por lo que se
podría imaginar y solo voy a hacer unos
pequeños números aquí que el joan era de
10 por dólar estamos aquí en la galería
nacional de arte en washington dc y
estamos observando venus consolando al
amor
de igual forma y ahora vamos a comparar
valor con el elemento que sigue a la
izquierda así que tenemos que disminuir
y ha concluido que la educación se trata
de dinero y prestigio y no de
convertirse en un mejor ser humano capaz
de hacer grandes cosas hoy no estoy aquí
para darles un panfleto de lo que se
debe hacer
no existe solo una manera de hacer esto
pero les vamos a dar muchas herramientas
hoy vamos a mostrarles muchas maneras de
hacer las cosas mejor pero depende de
ustedes tomar lo que les parezca útil
para su salón de clases y comenzar y van
a salir con una idea muy clara de cómo
quieren hacerlo luego los chicos les van
a responder a ustedes ya khan academy y
les prometo que la imagen con la que
comenzaron no será la misma con la que
terminen al final del año escolar y está
bien estén preparados para no cumplir
con esas expectativas mantengan una
actitud abierta a las respuestas sean
creativos en la solución de todos esos
problemas con los que se van a enfrentar
especialmente cuando los alumnos deciden
que quieren hacer algo para que la clase
sea emocionante será bueno que tengan
esa flexibilidad para adaptarse
así que esta es la mentalidad que
queremos que tengan hoy y también la que
nos gustaría que tuvieran cuando
implementen los contenidos en sus clases
y bueno cuando entran al sistema
educativo entran algo que es muy
complejo hay cosas que ocurren en las
escuelas que tendemos a darlas por un
hecho tomamos a todos los alumnos que
son más o menos de la misma edad los
ponemos en un salón y les enseñamos una
cierta materia 40 a 45 minutos suena la
campana los llevamos a otro salón les
enseñamos otra materia por 40 o 45
minutos suena la campana de nuevo
llevamos al mismo grupo de alumnos a
otro salón y esto ocurre día tras día
semana tras semana mes tras mes cuando
lo piensas detenidamente es una manera
bastante eficiente de educar a las masas
y bueno sabemos que una clase está llena
de individuos
siempre existe esa alumna que está
aburrida
y ya ha aprendido este tema durante el
verano con sus padres ya lo sabe también
tenemos a ese chico
aterrado muy asustado es nuevo en la
escuela y la escuela en donde iba tenía
unos programas de estudio completamente
diferentes o tal vez estuvo enfermo las
últimas semanas y no tiene la menor idea
de lo que está sucediendo hoy entonces
qué pasa con estos alumnos cualquiera
que sea la razón por la cual se están
quedando atrás a menudo vemos que tienen
unas bases muy débiles en matemáticas
cuando piensan en cómo construir una
casa imaginemos que todos juntos vamos a
construir una casa gigante
buscamos un arquitecto y le decimos
sabes tenemos tres meses para poner los
cimientos de esta casa el arquitecto
dice seguro no hay ningún problema
comienza a trabajar en los cimientos
pero un mes después empieza a llover se
está cayendo el cielo parece que no va a
terminar de llover
al final de los tres meses los cimientos
parecen estar listos pero hay muchos
puntos débiles el inspector de la
construcción llega y dice bueno los
cimientos les doy 80% porque todavía hay
algunos puntos débiles y decimos 80% con
eso pasa no os vamos a construir la
planta baja así que construimos la
planta baja digamos que tenemos 6 meses
para construir la planta baja le
explicamos al arquitecto dónde queremos
las habitaciones y dice perfecto cuatro
meses más tarde no conseguimos varilla
por ningún lado compramos todo lo que
había en existencia hay escasez por lo
que sea pero no podemos conseguir
varilla para terminar nuestra planta
baja hacemos lo mejor que podemos
traemos al inspector al final de los
seis meses y dice
se ve bien la planta baja hay unas
paredes un poco débiles podrían darle
más soporte pero les doy un 77 por
ciento de calificación 77% con eso
pasamos vamos a construir la planta alta
y luego un piso más que pasa al final
nuestra casa se derrumba
porque estamos construyendo encima de
cimientos muy débiles y no es error del
inspector de construcciones tampoco del
arquitecto y tampoco la nuestra ese
error de un proceso que requiere que
ciertas cosas se hagan en un cierto
lapso es decir vamos a asegurarnos que
las bases están bien para llevarte al
siguiente nivel esto es lo que vemos a
menudo en matemáticas y por eso vemos
muchos alumnos que tienen hoyos como
queso gruyère cuando llegan a nuestros
salones tenían un maestro que faltaba
ellos faltaban tuvieron que cambiar de
residencia lo que sea tienen hoyos como
queso gruyère y lo difícil de esto es
que no todos los alumnos tienen el mismo
hoyo tienen alumnos con problemas en
números negativos otro grupo de alumnos
que no entiende bien las fracciones lo
que sea hace que sea muy difícil
satisfacer cada una de las necesidades
de sus alumnos
entonces siempre me gusta comenzar con
esto porque este es el problema que khan
academy trata de resolver no se trata de
sentar a nuestros alumnos frente a una
computadora todo el día se trata de
resolver este problema
cuando pensamos en khan academy en el
salón de clases pensamos en tres pilares
centrales
el primero creemos que la educación debe
basarse en el dominio
quiero decir que realmente creemos que
el alumno debe dominar álgebra muy bien
antes de que pasen a cálculo
pensamos que el alumno debe saber
resolver ecuaciones de primer grado
antes de que resuelvan las de segundo
grado también pensamos que el
aprendizaje debe ser personalizado si
tienen un alumno que no tiene bien
aprendido un conocimiento específico por
ejemplo fracciones creemos que debe
tomarse su tiempo para remediar eso
aprender bien ese concepto antes de
continuar personalizar quiere decir
darle a cada quien el tiempo que
requiera y también permitirles saber
dónde se encuentran y hacia dónde van
darles la libertad de decir no estoy
lista para la siguiente elección
necesito más tiempo en esto el tercer
pilar es interactivo nosotros creemos
que los maestros y los alumnos deben
interactuar que debe haber un componente
social muy fuerte en la clase lo que
vemos en las clases es que los alumnos
se levantan ayudan a sus compañeros se
dan cuenta que pueden enseñar a alguien
más algo que sí saben qué maravilla
poder ver esto en sus clases
cuando un alumno puede ayudar a otro es
cuando sabes que ese alumno en verdad
entiende el concepto lo han
internalizado
creemos que ustedes deben poder analizar
la base de datos y decidir cuáles
alumnos están listos para salir de khan
academy y adentrarse en un proyecto más
práctico van a escuchar de tal y sony lo
interactivas que son sus clases ahora
gracias a las herramientas que khan
academy les brindó
cómo hacemos esto pensamos que la base
de datos es la clave la base de datos es
el vehículo que les permitirá decir a la
mitad de mi clase no está lista para la
elección de mañana mejor voy a trabajar
con ellos la base de datos es lo que te
permite personalizar ese aprendizaje
para cada alumno si tienes sólo un chico
que no entiende un concepto determinado
puede acceder a este material en nuestro
sitio y practicarlo la base de datos es
lo que te permite ver que ese otro
alumno será un tutor perfecto para ese
alumno débil o como sea que se necesite
así que hemos empezado a ver algo de
éxito en esto lo que ven aquí es el
reporte de un asesor en el eje
horizontal se encuentra el número de
días que han accedido al sitio y en el
eje vertical es el número de ejercicios
que se han completado cada una de estas
líneas es un alumno este es el reporte
de nuestra primera escuela piloto en los
altos pueden observar que este alumno en
particular
empezó digamos en la media
pero conforme pasaban los días este
alumno pudo trabajar en los ejercicios
específicos de acuerdo con sus propias
lagunas y para el final del periodo de
este año en can academy es el primero en
su clase
cuando les das a los alumnos la
oportunidad de resolver sus lagunas ves
cómo se acelera su progreso de una
manera que no habías previsto es
formidable porque vivimos bajo un
sistema en el cual los alumnos
generalmente se encuentran atrapados si
están atrapados en una clase de nivel
bajo o en una clase de matemáticas
promedio tal vez no crean o ni siquiera
se les dé la oportunidad de demostrar de
lo que son capaces en cada academic
queremos liberar ese potencial al darles
el tiempo y el acceso a los contenidos
que necesitan
el ejemplo que les dije es de un alumno
que está más en la media de su clase
también quiero hablar de un alumno que
está en la cúspide de su clase este es
un chico en una escuela privada un
programa piloto
hace dos años ya cuarto grado visite su
escuela durante el primer semestre uno
de esos días en que se les permite traer
sus muñecos de peluche si están
familiarizados con eso si era el día de
los muñecos de peluche en ese momento
usaban khan academy cada viernes
solamente para el segundo semestre ya lo
usaban todos los días cuando me acerqué
a él un día durante el segundo semestre
le pregunté dime qué estás aprendiendo
ahora en khan academy me enseñó paso a
paso cómo resolver polinomios por
factorización es un chico de 10 años que
estaba abrazando un muñeco de peluche
solo unos meses antes
es increíble normalmente trabajo con
secundarias y preparatorias y cuando
visité esta escuela este chico estaba
trabajando con el mismo material que los
chicos de 3º de secundaria o primero de
prepa es un ejemplo de un chico que
trabajó desde 11 con la idea de dominio
paso a paso de khan academy sin
restricciones nadie lo estaba deteniendo
estaba aprendiendo a una velocidad
impresionante y estos son contenidos a
los que en una situación normal no
hubiera accedido en el programa de
cuarto de primaria así que esta es otra
historia de éxito que hemos tenido
también quiero hablar de los maestros
porque todos ustedes son una parte
fundamental en este proceso quiero que
escuchen a algunos maestros hablar sobre
cómo está funcionando en sus salones de
clase
khan academy no permite que los alumnos
oculten sus carencias de conocimiento de
verdad te reta a que des clases
excelentes a tantos alumnos como puedas
porque tienes toda esta información
sobre tus alumnos
antes cuando no podían resolver algún
problema que se les asignaba de tareas
se detenían no no lo entiendo no lo voy
a hacer hay alguien can que lo seduce a
continuar empiezan a hacerse
responsables de su propio aprendizaje
dos minutos antes de que termine el
tiempo de matemáticas con khan academy
tocó la campana para que sepan que ya es
hora y ellos gritan y dicen
minutos más y esto siempre alegra un
maestro ver que los chicos no quieren
dejar de aprender probablemente no
vuelva a enseñar como lo hacía antes de
lo que vamos a estar hablando hoy es de
las mejores formas de enseñar que hemos
estado aprendiendo de nuestras escuelas
piloto aquí en la zona
me gusta mostrarles las escuelas en las
que hemos estado trabajando y también
trabajamos con muchas otras escuelas en
todo eeuu algunos maestros están aquí
ahora con nosotros pero solo piensen que
todo lo que están aprendiendo hoy tiene
su origen en situaciones reales
empezamos nuestro proyecto piloto en la
bahía de san francisco hace un par de
años pero sabemos que somos parte de
algo más grande aquí están algunas
cifras sobre nuestro sitio
estamos en 29 mil salones
aproximadamente cada año hay entre 2 y 3
millones de problemas de matemáticas que
se resuelven en nuestro sitio
así que forman parte de algo muy grande
y muy emocionante
y cuando tengan esos momentos de
frustración o de angustia les pido que
recuerden que son parte de una comunidad
más grande y que estamos aquí tratando
de resolver juntos cómo funciona esto
quiero mostrarles ahora a este chico
zack morris del programa salvados por la
campana cuando yo era niña y veía este
programa pensaba esos celulares nunca
van a pegar son grandes incómodos y se
ven tontos
ahora los celulares son lo uso para
llegar al trabajo encuentro indicaciones
para ir a cualquier lado mando correos
lo uso para muchas cosas para mí es un
dispositivo mágico
me gusta traer esto a colación porque
cuando pensamos en tecnología en las
revoluciones en los grandes movimientos
siempre tienen un punto de partida y
normalmente este inicio no es
particularmente glamoroso todos ustedes
están aquí hoy porque les interesa una
tecnología nueva que les puede ayudar en
sus clases y queremos ayudarles a llegar
ahí pero también queremos dejar claro
que no somos de ninguna manera una bala
de plata siendo honestos somos un poco
como este celular torpe tenemos todavía
un gran camino por recorrer estamos
aprendiendo de todos ustedes todos los
días para mejorar
queremos llegar a un lugar mejor
pero hoy todavía somos un poco torpes
queremos que todos ustedes se
familiaricen con el sitio y queremos que
empiecen a pensar cómo me gustaría que
funcionara así me gustaría que tuviera
esta funcionalidad me gustaría poder
hablar con mis alumnos a través del
sitio o lo que sea queremos llegar allá
pero en este momento estamos muy
contentos de que estén aquí con nosotros
queremos que recorren este viaje con
nosotros que nos dejen saber cómo poder
mejorar
mi consejo ahorita para ustedes para el
resto del día e incluso después del
taller de hoy es que empiecen sencillo
pero simplemente empiecen es la mejor
forma de usar khan academy no necesitan
un plan perfecto no necesitan a todo su
equipo solo necesitan empezar con sus
alumnos y ver cómo responden
desde el tiempo y espacio necesarios
para familiarizarse con el sitio y todo
evolucionará a partir de allí van a
escucharme repetir esto mucho hoy se van
a hartar de escucharme repetir esto pero
este es mi mejor consejo empieza
sencillo pero empieza